foreign
[Music]
ERS show I'm your host Paul aka the guy
who's got a fin Rod like galadriel's
brother in this video we're breaking
down episode 4 of the Rings of power the
series is now at its halfway point and
though it still feels like it's in setup
mode we are getting some things moving
in terms of where we could be heading
throughout this video we're going to be
breaking it all down and going through
the connections to the books as well as
the nods to the movies there will be
some future book spoilers here in
regards to both a lindial and asildo as
they feature in the films but other
characters like farazone I'll keep quiet
on however if that could ruin the show
for you then turn off now and without
the way let's get into the video
foreign
[Music]
though we later learn it's a vision
given by the palantir it prophesizes the
fall of the city and the destruction of
the entire Kingdom this is ushered in by
the petals falling from the white tree
which is known as nimloth this bad Omen
signals the end and a giant tidal wave
role saying that gets rid of this city
and all those bad reviews though it's
initially just a nightmare come the end
of the entry rewatch as the petals fall
and it's somewhat the second stage of
the Doom that's Tudor before the kingdom
the first stage of this was galadriel's
arrival and it's all sort of falling
into place with us watching the events
line up so that everything can come
crashing down the Dream Begins With
Muriel gritting babies who are very much
metaphors for the future of the Kingdom
they are of course killed by the tidal
wave as well symbolically showing how
the future of numenor is completely
[ __ ] killing kids in the first couple
of minutes it's dark but I also respect
it now one thing that I didn't mention
in my last video is that numenoreans
have much longer life spans than normal
men do typically they live for 300 to
350 years and these babies being snuffed
out is an even bigger tragedy because
man could have had 300 years of being a
heavy spoiler subscriber what do you
mean you also hated the show now I'm
probably going to get some dislikes but
I actually really like this opening and
though I knew it was a dream as soon as
the waves rolled in it was a nice tease
to show what people know is coming the
fall of numenor is often referenced
throughout the books and movies and
seeing this Devastation was a really
gripping way to start things off whether
it held up as we got on we'll get into I
thought the beginning was at least very
solid now from here we go to the
blacksmith member from last week now
sporting a black eye courtesy of Hal
brand he how branded him and he's gone
from we don't take too kindly to you in
these parts to the next stage of that
which is like the card yeah
this is weaponized by farazone who
unites the public distrust for elves in
order to turn people against the queen
it's all a political play and we slowly
start to see as he sows the seeds of
doubt in her rule I don't want to get
too heavy into the book spoilers because
this channel it's not called heavy
spoilers is it but this division is a
big part of the story and we can see a
coup slowly stung to be set up he gives
a big speech in front of a hall that has
images of Builders embossed into it and
very much uses this as a backdrop to
pretend that he's a man of the people he
mentions the creation of the sea wall
which was used to stop water flowing
into the kingdom and also the raising of
our menelos which is the great City that
the scenes take place in you very much
plants the idea in everyone's mind that
if the queen works with Galadriel that
the people of the capital will be
replaced and no doubt will use his fear
even more after the events of the ending
here we also meet his son Kevin who is a
new creation for the show man has got
game and he ends up taking Iranian for
dinner I'm always butchering these names
and I apologize and you know what the
dislikes are probably deserved I think
this is all a double play with him just
doing it so that he can get her family
on his side as well as a path to El
India who's now in the Queen's Council a
lean deal was of course blackmail last
week into working with her and he might
be able to be swayed against her rule
again none of this stuff is in the book
so don't take it as gospel but the play
by Kevin could have a double sight to it
but the characters are New Creations for
the show and I am interested to see
where they go with it now as far as on
got older he slowly became more and more
bitter that he was aging and wished to
gain the immortality that the elves had
this is where a certain Dark Lord came
into play and I think we might even
learn that he's been using the palantir
to contact him similar Saruman back with
the queen Galadriel brings the warning
of Sauron as well as the reveal that Hal
brand is the King of the South Muriel
does a joke about lindial being a runic
Emperor and these were known as
easterlings who lived in the east of
Mordor in the lands of roon they were
enemies of the three people and they
have eventually sided with Sauron just
in case we meet any
spoiler alert
now Galadriel wants a union between the
numenoreans like the days of old so that
they can stop Sauron in the Southlands
as we now know the Southlands will
eventually become mortal and we're very
much watching the creation of sauron's
Realm throughout the series this is why
tunnels are being built rather than the
Orcs just traveling at night and they
very much want to create a way for them
to move around freely in the Southlands
without having to wait for cloud cover
or for the sun to go down this guy is a
Mordor of course ended up getting
blanketed in Ash due to Mount Doom and
these tunnels could provide a passage to
it because their tunnels I feel like the
trenches are being dug so that something
can be moved through them and it may be
the forge that Sauron uses to create the
One Ring we see the Elven one is about
halfway done in this entry and though he
might not use a forge because I don't
think it popped up in the book they are
definitely planning on using these for
something big and after giving a speech
about how Galadriel wants to see the
manager AKA Muriel's father she's thrown
in jail for sedition which basically
means she's saying things that could
cause a rebellion should pay attention
to people closer to home and next we
jump across the sea to a seal door
weirdly we get a moment in which he
hears Whispering voices which are
presented in a similar way to how the
ring speaks to him he hears his voice
and lets gather up on purpose showing
how this has the power to tempt him with
a darker path much like how that did I
think this is calling him to Middle
Earth which is why he signs about the
end however it could be letting him know
to go with his heart and he of course
said last week that he didn't want to do
the sea trial from the ship we can also
see men ultarma and this great Mountain
was seen as a holy site by the
numenoreans now there's lots of
foreshadowing here with his buddy
implying that he only got to do the sea
trial because of who his father is this
very much carries across to the
character's future as well with him only
really getting the ring because of his
father's sacrifice a lean deal was
struck down by Sauron and then his seal
door took his blade up and cut off the
Dark Lord's hand which allowed him to
take the ring it's pretty much only
because of his father's falling that the
opportunity rose up so I feel like
that's what they're playing up to here
to foreshadow the future chair only deal
eventually also ends up becoming a great
king which allows his son to follow in
his footsteps showing that a seal door
ain't [ __ ] now one thing that Middle
Earth shadow of War told us is that a
sealed or actually ended up becoming one
of the Nazgul again I don't think this
is regarded as Canon so don't lose your
[ __ ] [ __ ] for me bring it up I said
don't lose it anyway after he was
attacked by the Orcs they took his body
to Sauron who then used to Ring to
revive him he was tortured and
transformed into one of The Naz ghoul
and he became a servant of Sauron again
probably not canon but it would be
interesting to see them maybe create the
ring rates in the show don't think the
series will probably end with the big
battle it would be great if that was a
season 3 thing and we then got to see
the events after a play out with lots of
characters seeking the ring before it
falls to the riverbed either way a seal
door is told that he's the problem and
this conflicted character has a dark
path ahead of him elsewhere with arondia
we are finally introduced to Adar after
the tease from last week played by Jose
it more this dark elf is also a new
creation for the series though lots of
people think that he might be an alias
of Sauron I don't think that they would
have spelled it out to us straight away
if that was the case the first time we
hear characters talking about him they
say he could be the dark lord and I
think this is way too obvious if it's
gonna be a big reveal now in addition to
this he also brings up how he went down
the river of valerian when he was
younger which I don't think Sauron would
be fully familiar with Valerian existed
in the first age but it ended up being
destroyed during the war of Wrath which
wiped out most of the land there
although Sauron was about doing this I
don't think that he would be able to
recount places like this in such detail
now as we saw with the likes of sarumon
Sauron has the potential to corrupt
everyone around him and no no elves had
this happen to them in the books the
show is obviously saying [ __ ] the cannon
in the source material thano carried out
some elf on elf violence which was a big
moment known as the kinsling so the
foundation is there for elves to turn on
elves and judge by his scars he was
probably tortured by either the Orcs or
Sauron himself he ends up killing the
down dog from last week and in a nice
bit of attention to detail we can
actually see that he's wearing the end
chest piece that are on the air and the
others head on the Orcs won't carry the
weak and a dog kills him maybe he should
just join the half foots because they're
very much survival of the fittest too
bloody monsters now I've got a lot of
flashes of Apocalypse Now with him being
very much a fallen Commander that talks
about the lies of society I kind of
think that'll be revealed that the elves
betrayed him and who knows he may even
be a Survivor from the kinsling now last
week we also talked about how the first
orc reminded us of the one from The Two
Towers turns out that it's because it's
actually the same actor and huge shell
outstandard of the Rings are pointing
out that this is Jed Brophy he also play
Nori in The Hobbit and is now featured
in every live-action Lord of the Rings
project over at the album Tower we
learned that they're running low on
rations and this is due to every village
from around the area showing up there
they are volunteers to go to world
Drake's Root Cellar and he ends up
further powering at the Black Blade
again I feel like this is a mogul one
and he watches at once more reforms like
that one evaporated although this was a
really well put together scene and I
love how the cloud rolled in and started
to blanket the landscape the air is
attacked by an orc who licks the blade
and this is similar to what the urakai
leader ugluk did in The Fellowship of
the Rings Theo's plan to escape goes
well
and also got flashes of the hobbits
lying low under the tree with parts of
the well almost sticking out like a
branch back at a region we watches the
great forges belt and Caleb rimboard did
say that he had a deadline in which to
create it I think this might be because
Anita gave him a day to do it in and in
case you don't know this was a disguise
used by Sauron to manipulate the elves
known as the Lord of gifts he appeared
to them as a friend and the creation of
his Forge could have been instructed by
him what about the character might not
have emerged yet due to his arrival
being said to be tied with the Starfall
that brought the stranger with it in the
book Sauron arrived from the Shadows but
they may have changed it up if our
theories about the stranger being him
are true now I say that if they're true
I don't think it's the case that he is
Sauron and I think that Sauron probably
rose up and then the stranger was sent
in by elevator as a way to counter him I
think the stranger is probably gonna be
revealed to be Gandalf which is why
Amazon haven't told us his full name yet
and though he doesn't arrive in the
timeline until much later Amazon didn't
spend billions on this show to have it
be some Rando now Keller brimble brings
up elrond's father or indiel who was
half Alvin known for carrying out a
great Voyage single-handedly to valinor
he was said to have been elevated to
carry a star across the sky the
character was prophesied to return and
all this talk of him here makes me think
that they might they might bloody do it
in the show might have him come back
anyways
foreign
ER could even be elrond's dad as he
arrived in a Starfall and they keep
prophesizing his return would make sense
be a good surprise and give elrond a
chance to spend more time with his dad
like what he says to jiren very quick
Theory that's in a theory type
Ocala brimbor said that he said the
future would lie in his son's hands or
telling how elrond would become the Lord
of Rivendell by that color brimble hints
that he believes it's in the great Forge
which of course ties into the ring he
says that jiren is hiding something from
him and we later learn that this is me
thrill got a bloody Theory time right
and elron visits diesel before
discovering the truth
now we can hear gooder and gamley
playing the knocking game in the
background and this light helps alaron
to open the secret doorway dwarves are
of course famous for hiding passages and
we saw in the fellowship how the
entrance to Moria was only revealed
through the use of moonlight I'm still
not sure whether that doorway we saw in
episode 2 was the same one but let me
know below if you think it is now on the
floor we can see the dragon Helm of door
Loman model which was said to be made by
the Dwarven Smith telcar he also created
the sword narcel which was used against
Sauron and I think we might even get an
appearance by it later on in the entry
after elves dropping a eavesdropping
elves dropping on them elrond picks up
that they're digging in the old mine and
he travels out there Kaza Doom is still
full of lush plant life due to the
dwarves being able to redirect sunlight
and this is something that Gandalf also
tapped into during The Fellowship of the
Ring elrond does the old five six seven
eight who do we appreciate and gets
through to the secret compartment where
jiren tells them about the new discovery
now Andy kind of funny recently pointed
out that the elves don't have sideburns
because it's probably to do with the air
Prosthetics since realizing this it's
ruined the show for me and I'm now
telling it to you too because I won't
have anyone having fun under my watch
Metro was of course a very valuable acid
and this should Bilbo found that saved
his and Frodo's life several times was
made of the material elron ends up
taking an oath to not share the info
with anyone but I think that he may tell
Keller brimble which will cause a lot of
issues a quest to get me thrill of
course caused the dwarves to dig deeper
and deeper and this eventually led to
them digging where they shouldn't have
been decent brought up in episode 2 that
they would sing to the stone and this
would show them the way this is so much
shown in the entry later on with diesel
belting out a banger that causes the
environment to react this is to release
the bodies of those that get trapped
while sticking but it's also used as a
way to open things up in the end though
this foolishness LED them to init the
balrog we know from the trailers that
one will be showing up so I'm expecting
the mithral quest to caused them to come
across one in the caves durian's father
during the third wish to have caution
when digging I am expecting him to die
at some point in the series which will
make our boy during King he will
probably want to dig deeper and further
and this will lead to the fall of
kazadum now in prison how Brian tells
Galadriel to stop storming and demanding
stuff and that this has made her lose
sight of the thing right in front of her
face he's much more charming and managed
to get not only her dagger but also the
crest by complimenting and playing
people I think the character of Hal bran
is a really interesting one and though
he's definitely the Aragorn of the show
he's got a darker side to him though
he's really Charming he's also just
playing characters to get ahead which
shows he will lie to get power I think
if he was revealed to eventually become
the witch King that it would be a great
direction to take things and as we know
the kings of men are eventually turned
into them he even seems to manipulate
farazone into letting Galadriel leave by
letting him know where she's going so
he's clearly just out for himself a
senior pushing away away from that worm
mate I seen tit now Galadriel manages to
escape and she climbs a tower which is
based on Elvish one's which we can see
due to its design as mentioned last week
the city was gifted to the men by the
elves due to them standing up against
morgoth his kingdom is vast and
expansive later inspiring the designs of
ministereth it shows how those that
worked with the elves benefited from it
this idea of elves and Men working
together is showcased in the prior scene
with a seal door and his sister due to a
mural on the wall showcasing the two
races fighting alongside each other this
itself is against a fish dragon in the
sundering sea which featured in episode
2 and also on the maps Galadriel finds
the king bedridden basically showing
that he's on his way out Muriel doesn't
want this getting out as it could cause
an even further power struggle and with
her leaving the kingdom I think farazon
will use him as a way to weaponize all
the people against her the King was of
course an ally to the elves so this
might cause further descent amongst the
population we hear about the rebellion
of the people and how Mario bill was put
in place to rule and obviously if they
find out he's been nursed then it will
cause a lot of issues Muriel takes
Galadriel to the palantir and I believe
that we see nozzle at this point if you
look at the handle it looks exactly the
same and we know from The Source
material that after it was forged in the
first age that it ended up yet this
weapon was later used by a Lin deal
before it sealed or picked it up to
strike Sauron so it might get passed on
to him directly from the queen Galadriel
touches the palantir and it further
showcases the same vision that numenor
will fall Muriel misinterprets this as
being caused by the elves who could take
back the island but as you can probably
guess it's caused by Sauron yes spoiler
alert there now Theo makes a break for
it in the night and I really like how
the character has been used for a lot of
the more horror film sequences there was
the orc scene in episode 2 and this one
takes shows as he tries to avoid
detection when the Orcs are at the most
powerful sure he sounds like a cast
member of Coronation Street but the
character is growing on me however think
that our India's arrival kind of doesn't
make sense when you think that adore
released him the way a daughter treat
the dying orc of the Stark was very
sympathetic and it made me think that he
might be an alcoholic
[Music]
so I don't know why he let her on the F3
carrying lots of weapons as he could
just use them against the Orcs and guess
what he did either way we still get a
solid chase scene with the elf doing the
reverse UNO card when he catches an
arrow once more they use a lot of slow
motion but it actually felt way more
impactful than last episode due to it
being tense whereas that just felt like
an over-reliance they make it out of the
tree line into the safety of the sun
once more cementing why the Orcs are
digging trenches reminded me a lot of
the bit when they escaped Moria men have
to move fast before Sundown due to the
Orcs starting to swarm the area diesel
apologizes for lying to elrond and we
discover that jiren managed to pull the
Trap dwarves out he clearly resents his
father and the show again has switched
things up from the Canon the dwarves
were believed to be reincarnations of
those that came before with during the
fourth being believed to be during the
first however his dad was also supposed
to be reincarnated from during the first
so I don't know but at least it's not as
complicated as a Game of Thrones family
tree 3 and they have a line about how
the wisdom of the pride dwarf Kings
flows into the new one to talk about
mistakes and the only mistake here was
you not pulling out now either way
elrond makes jiren realize that time is
running short with his dear old dad and
that they should cherish the time they
have together June the third actually
appears in the fellowship prologue and
he's one of the dwarves that is given a
ring of power this later is passed to
his son so I am expecting during the
fourth to wield one at some point and
for his dad to live a long time or at
least up till maybe season three now he
ends up visiting his father and he
apologizes for digging too deep but the
old man tells him that he's with him
either way this pretty much gives him
permission to keep digging which we know
the outcome of he also grants him leave
to go and visit Linden which will tell
them of the forge and likely be a way
that they put a ring on it back with her
on the air we seize he brings the
message that they have to disappear like
half the audience of the show and we
learn that there are spies amongst them
this comes in the form of the barman
walldrig who is still loyal to the
forces of evil the men of course made a
pact with morgoth and we discovered that
waldrig was the one who owned the hilt
in episode 1 we heard how the Orcs were
experimenting with the Unseen World and
I think much in the same way that the
Mogul blade pulled Frodo into it that
the health will be used to potentially
pull Sauron out Adara is alerted to its
location and I have to hand it to him in
his walks that the men don't stand a
chance the entry ends with collateral
being sent away from the kingdom but
after the petals fall she's called back
and Muriel decides to travel to Middle
Earth farazan says an issue that the
people will be relieved but on the
change of plans he stands as an opposite
to her symbolizing how he's against her
in the end we see a seal door signing up
Hal brand appears to be free possibly
because he snitched a farazone and
they're all heading out in 10 days which
I hope we don't see because I don't want
to spend 10 more days just going we have
to get going
please just move on with it now as for
my thoughts on the entry again I thought
this had its moments but I wish the show
would just get things moving as it still
feels like it's setting things up rather
than progressing the plot we're now four
hours deep and now the Lord of the Rings
films will empty they'd covered way more
ground in the fellowship by this point
I'm hoping next week that they all hit
Middle Earth and finally take a stand
against the Orcs instead of just
Galadriel trying to convince people that
they should I feel that's my main
criticism with it and I hope next week
we just hit the ground running instead
of her constantly saying Sauron is
coming you have to fight that's why I
feel the pace is being dragged down but
I can imagine that the Harford Caravan
will probably take up a big part of it
too since it was missing from this one
now as for the good I think the orondia
and Theo bits were really strong along
with elrond disa and the during scenes
I've always found the elves a bit stoic
and rapid and the kind of Charisma
vacuums due to them being above everyone
therefore I think it's smart when
they're played off against others who
have more personality as as it allows
them to gain some I felt this about the
relationship with Legolas and Gimli yeah
dislikes there I feel that both elrond
and Galadriel are at their best when
they're working off others so all in all
I think the episode was okay I don't
think it's as terrible as a lot of
people are saying but I also don't think
that it's as gripping as it could be it
has a difficult task of going up against
House of the Dragon which for me
outperforms it every week it's
unfortunate as again the visuals are
really next level in this and I hope
that the second part of the season has
more going on with it than the first now
as always I think there's going to be a
ton of different opinions on the show so
let me know yours below I went from
being called a shill one week to a hater
the next one and this week I'm probably
gonna be a fencer because I said it was
okay so let me know below I'll try I'll
try and navigate these reviews as best
as I can and yeah I'd love to hear your
thoughts as well just to let you know
we're running competition right now and
giving away three copies of dollar and
thunder on the 15th of October all you
have to do to be on the chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and drop
a comment below with your thoughts on
the episode we pick the comments at
random at the end of the month and the
winners of the last one are on screen
right now save that to you then message
me on Twitter at heavy spoilers if you
want something else to watch then make
sure you check out our breakdown of
House of the Dragon which will be linked
on screen right now we've gone over all
the ties to the books what we think is
going to be happening with the
characters and just our general thoughts
on it so head over there right after
this by the way thanks for sticking
through the video I've been poor you
take care yourself peace